e
public de tous ces hommages.
Lafleur, bonjour.
- Bonjour.
- Merci de nous recevoir chez
vous. D'abord, au nom de toute
l'équipe de Radio-Canada, nos
condoléances pour Guy.
- Merci.
- Lise, soeur de Guy Lafleur,
nos condoléances également
à toute la famille élargie.
- Merci beaucoup.beaucoup.beauc.
- C'est triste de devoir
enterrer un garçon.
- Oui, c'est très triste.
- Première chose que j'ai envie
de vous demander, vous le
saviez, évidemment, il était
très malade, mais ça reste dur
d'enterrer un garçon.
PIERRETTE LAFLEUR
mère de Guy Lafleur(&
- J'ai demandé à son père la
veille que j'ai été à Montréal
le voir la dernière fois, j'aidr
chercher Guy, oui.
Puis j'ai été exaucée, oui.
- Vous n'étiez plus capable
de le voir souffriir souffriir ?
- Non, non. Moi, je n'étais plus
capable de le voir endurer
- C'était votre garçon, mais là,
vous le voyez depuis une
semaine, tout le monde l'aime.
- Oui, oui.
- C'est comme si c'est un membre
de la famille qui est parti.
Ça vous touche de voir tous ces
gens-là qui ont de la peine?
- Oui. Je trouve qu'il a été
bien aimé par le public.
Le public l'aimait beaucoup.
Moi, quand Guy venait se
promener à Thurso, même Guy,
quand il dinait, bien là, il
arrivait quelqu'un. Quelqu'un
avec des photos, un chandail
à faire signer. Je leur disais :
attendez, je vais lui demander.
Là, il disait : oui, c'est
correct. Il venait à la table,
là, il le dérangeait.
Guy, ça ne lui faisait rien, il
aimait ça. Il était généreux.
- L'avez-vous déjà vu dire
non à quelqu'un?
- Non. Je l'ai jamais vu, non,
parce que, coudonc, il
appartenait à tout le monde,
puis j'étais fière pour lui.
- Lise, on voit défiler... on
est dimanche, ça va être comme
ça jusqu'à demain soir. C'est
le le monde à Montréal
qui vont le voir. Ça vous
étonne? Ça vous fait quoi de
voir ça?
LISE LAFLEUR
soeur de Guy Lafleur
- Bien, c'est émouvant.
- Oui.
- On savait qu'il était aimé,
mais c'est comme inimaginable de
voir ça. C'est gros. C'est comme
s'il appartenait à tout... c'est
comme le frère.
- Il appartient à tout le monde.
- Oui.
- C'est notre ami.
- C'est comme si on le prêtait.
- Parce qu'on sava
rassemblait. Guy Lafleur,
il rassemblait :
les souverainistes,
les indépendantistes,
les fédéralistes, les pauvres,
les gens de toutes les régions.
Il avait le don, tout le monde
l'aimait, de rassembler le
monde. Il n'y en a plus
beaucoup, il n'y en a pas
beaucoup, des gens qui ont fait
ça dans notre hist
- Non, ça a été une exception.
Il est né et puis je sais pas,
on dirait que ça s'est fait tout
seul. Il était charismatique,
très près du monde.
- Je veux dire merci de m'avoir
donné votre appui, votre
enthusiatout votre
amour.
(applaud
- Mardi, quand vous allez être
en la cathédrale Marie-Reine-du-
Monde, qlez
avoir en tête, mardi?
Ça va être difficile?
- Je vais avoir en tête qu'il
repose en paix. Il a finimal, p,
je sais pas. Il n'était plus
capable. Non, non. Mais je
trouve ça bien triste, oui.
Puis je sais pas qu'est-ce que
ça va me faire. Me semble que je
ne serais pas là. Je vais être
là, mais je ne serai pas dans
mon corps.
- On comprend.
- J'ai dit : c'est moi qui
aurais dû partir.
, maman!
- Bien oui, oui.
- Bien non.
- Oui, mais c'est pas comme ça,
malheureusement.
- C'est la vie, c'est...- C'est.
Lise, vous allez donc avec vos
soeurs être là aussi mardi.
Ça va être difficile?
- Oui, ça va être difficile.
Oui, très difficile. Je sais pas
comment est-ce qu'on...
Ça me
de voir tous les hommages et
puis qu'est-ce qu'il va se
passer à la cathédrale.
ouvant.
- On sera là. Merci beaucoup de
nous avoir reçus.
- Bienvenue.